I recently became aware of a live stream
dating podcast on the whatever YouTube
channel case would you rather smash the
hottest trans woman in the world or the
oldest woman in the world honestly bro
the oldest woman in the world because
then I wouldn't be gay because I have an
opinion that differs from yours
to technically be homosexual
a trans woman is a biological man sue me
it's I'm not allowed to say that I'm not
allowed to say that
[Music]
we can't blame her really for for not
being able to intelligently articulate
her objection to this man's point of
view on the subject what a concept it is
an unintelligible objection rooted in
her unthinking allegiance to gender
ideology which is also unintelligible